so when I sold my business I didn't know
what I wanted to do it was great I had
money awesome but I didn't know what I
wanted to do next and I said yes to a
whole bunch of things and one of them
was a guy who was in Venture Capital who
was part of a firm and I was curious
about raising money didn't I didn't know
how to do it because I never had to and
he brought me under his wing I joined a
venture capital firm for a year and a
half learned about all sorts of
different Industries and that wasn't my
forever thing that was my next thing
that then led to this and I've been
doing this I've been helping
entrepreneurs but that being said like
if I stopped liking videos I would just
walk away from YouTube because you'll
never win doing work that you hate
you're trying to answer a hard question
with your head the head would be yeah
staying the same thing get more
experience go keep learning get better
improve build more contact stay in real
estate that's logically what you should
do problem is if your heart's not into
it you're not gonna win you need to tap
into heart more and it'll make you a
more successful business person
I came back to the the community after
um basically from covid joining a firm
um but kind of going through these
iterations of doing everything that you
inspire and advised me to do but
unfortunately the environment's a little
uh super intense and very stressful and
kind of toxic but I keep putting my head
down to pursue it at the goal of being
uh of being a partner so at the end of
last year because the projections didn't
come true uh based on what I was brought
under the Compensation Plan
um basically I was incentivized that
there would be a partnership agreement
this year
um and so Tuesday we went to lunch
finally after monthly talks with the CEO
from July to now and uh did not come out
what was I expecting and what I was
enticed for this whole time and so now
I'm trying to keep my head down and stay
focused and keep the positive North
light but I feel very Rocky in my career
career again versus having this goal of
growing with people and having a bigger
impact than doing everything on my own
and so the question is
how to figure that out so I've had a
couple talks with mentors around this
and I know talked about Zan and some of
the others in the community and it's
about building a brand Do Your Own Thing
what I realized for myself is I'm a very
extroverted person I'm complimented
better when I'm in a component of a team
versus being a solopreneur
um I'm you know I'm good at strategy put
it you know impacting others or
communicating marketing
Investments and like wealth building but
now it's to figure out
where do I go to have that larger impact
and do what you said which is have that
North Star that continues to be that and
I think one of the challenges from covet
is I had ownership of my trajectory is
part of a business for our partners and
businesses now I don't have ownership
over my income and financial funds and
trajectory and that's been constraining
me because I'm not doing as well as I
was prior to covet you just don't have
ownership of your trajectory inside this
company
but you still have ownership of your
trajectory for where you could go and
that is a important mental distinction
for you as well that it's not over and
you're not screwed for life and you're
not
permanently stuck and it doesn't mean
you have to go quit this job right now
and go without a parachute you know into
the Brave New World you know you don't
want to start a company at least not yet
awesome and what's great is you know
kind of what you want to do like having
that North Star you don't you don't need
to be stuck on the how you know you want
to have a bigger impact you know you
want to have ownership you you know you
want to serve more you know you want to
work with a team you know you want to
have a boss that supports you mentors
you guides you and and values you great
how all that happens you don't have to
you like you'll never figure out those
steps from where you are right now
and that's okay why is that because the
way that my brain is wired is to think
about the Tactical point I hear you say
that all the time but I don't understand
it because I think about reverse
engineering yeah and there's nothing
wrong and listen I'm the same way like
goal oriented what's the plan how how
how let's go
I love that that's the best the problem
is there's too many variables that you
don't understand
so your plan right now is based off of
what you currently know and you don't
know enough so your plan has a million
holes in it
so it doesn't mean don't have a plan
but recognize that your plan is very
basic compared to what you're going to
make
and this is why there's a problem or at
least I have a problem I think with five
or ten year goals
because you just don't know like go back
to meet from 10 years ago whatever plan
like you've been goal oriented and plan
oriented you know most of your adult
life probably so if you go back look at
you from five years ago or ten years ago
you know samit in in 2015 making his
plan for 2022 you're not here
because 2015 samit has just different
information
he doesn't know what he knows now
and so there's a it's an audacity to
then think well I can I know where I'm
going to be in the next five years or
seven years or what my plan is going to
be so you make your best guess at a plan
like don't let that be so overwhelming
that you do nothing because that's the
worst
sure your your plan is to
start talking to a lot of people until
you create an opportunity
do you think there's any uh necessary
steps I think this was the so I was in
in the Big Four County in New York City
and I've tried to stay within the
umbrella of real estate but I realize I
don't need to always say to that but do
you think that there's unnecessary focus
of staying in a in a I don't know it's a
Continuum of your skill set development
so that you're not jumping from one
thing for two to three years and then
another thing for another two three
years I think about it as momentum but I
think that's also what prevents me from
going to other areas yeah similarly so
this is like the very first question
that's a hard question
you're trying to answer a heart question
with your head yeah the head would be
yeah staying the same thing get more
experience go keep learning get better
improve build more contact stay in real
estate that's logically what you should
do yeah the problem is if your heart's
not into it you're not going to win so
if you're going to be going off and
learning some new skill because that's
what's in your heart to go off and do it
may it may be it may feel like a step
back but it ends up creating a thousand
steps forward
because if you just stay in real estate
what you're gonna do if it's not at you
in your heart you're going to learn to
hate it more and more and more and more
and more every day
and it's the right strategy head wise
for who you are right now and what you
know but it's not what you actually want
to become
now it doesn't mean you go off and dump
it all and become a vegan Chef I don't
know or maybe it is
you know that's your thing but you'll
have a it'll be a temporary setback as
you go and learn that thing and it
doesn't sound like you're like an all-in
kind of guy you want to make your steps
to make progress so I would explore I
think the best thing you can do right
now is you have your intention which is
awesome
now you go explore
you go explore you start talking to
people you start talking to mentors you
start asking questions you do the
Outreach from people in your industry
and say hey I'm I'm uh I'm a young
professional in this industry I'd love
to pick your brain for 20 minutes I'm
stuck in a kind of career choice right
now
and whatever kind of personal connection
you can make whether it's at the company
maybe there's an alumni from the same
University that you went to maybe it's a
friend of a friend of a friend to line
up as many sessions with with potential
mentors as possible and something good
will happen
um very helpful I think that happened to
me like so when I sold my business I
didn't know what I wanted to do it was
great I had money awesome but I didn't
know what I wanted to do next and I said
yes to a whole bunch of things and one
of them was a guy who was in Venture
Capital who's part of a firm and I was
curious about raising money didn't I
didn't know how to do it because I never
had to
and he brought me under his wing and I I
joined the Venture Capital firm for a
year and a half
learned about all sorts of different
Industries and and that wasn't my
forever thing that was my next thing
that then led to this
and I've been doing this I've been
helping entrepreneurs for wow I don't
know how many years YouTube alone has
just been 12 years
um but that being said like if you if I
stopped liking videos
I would I would just walk away from
YouTube
next
because you'll never win doing work that
you hate I've done that like my website
was the thing that was making me a lot
of money I used to have a what I mean my
website was off my name we had a hundred
something thousand pages of content
making money every day from advertising
and Partnerships and brand deals and all
that stuff and it'd start to feel more
like a job
and um I just didn't like it and I was
really enjoying video making YouTube so
I overnight
shut down my website
put up a picture
to say you know working on it coming
soon
and now you can't find any of that old
content
on the site
and for me it's a much more Vibe thing
like logically it doesn't make any sense
but it ended up it works out because it
when you follow your heart great things
happen now I'm here if I stuck doing the
website I would hate my life
all right I appreciate that I don't want
to take up too much time so um very
helpful I think I am much more logic
driven when I look at like evaluation so
try I I have a lot of heart but I tend
to make these type of bigger decisions
with logic so trying to even though you
say follow your it's a little bit
challenging for me to make that switch
it's the only thing that matters though
for this
like this is the this is the ultimate
skill to learn
for big decisions like this it doesn't
mean like the concern then becomes oh we
get too emotional and then I just do
whatever comes into my head and with a
little no you're not you're never going
to be that guy you're never going to be
Reckless
yeah but for big imagine if you're
getting married
you better love her
as opposed to well logically you know
like it makes sense
I think it's probably both of those
right but it better be a lot of low
expectations
it better be a lot more on the love
on the logic
yeah like you see a lot of the guys who
have been married for a while like oh my
gosh I hope he gets this like I'm not
married yet so that's one of the reasons
like this is this isn't this is a skill
set to start to trust your heart which
you need you need both
there are some people who only listen to
the heart and are like doing all sorts
of crazy things and never say consistent
on anything and and never listen to the
head and never stay focused never gets
that's not you you're the opposite yeah
so you need you need to tap into heart
more and it'll make you a more
successful
business person human how I know you
don't like to focus on how do you tap
into the heart is like I guess the last
question when you feel
something come through you
when you get an idea
your next step is when you get an idea
go do something on it
yeah two percent rule two percent
difference right so when you get an idea
what you will do is automatically start
to plan it and judge it and come up with
everyone's holding up the special
Cleveland Edition
I got that copy as well 2019 tour let's
go yeah that's it like when you get an
idea do something on it and and the good
news is it's all low risk like what
what's your next idea but to to train
yourself that great ideas flow through
you and to take some immediate action on
it this is what I did because I'm much
more logical and strategic
I I was like you and I had to train
myself to do more heart
first
big decisions with your heart because if
you go into your next career or your
next relationship just doing logic first
you're always going to be unhappy
I appreciate it thank you Evan I'll I'll
report back on how that goes oh man keep
us posted Chris in the house what do we
got man so I'm looking at like this
whole like the Fast Five part
um
and start reaching out to people
um the amazing content 10 pack
everything else I guess my question is
for the kind of search that I would be
looking for
um you know I'm looking for the 40 plus
mail that is dealing with
um the quote-unquote dad bod issue and
stuff like that and wanting to get
himself in a better shape uh
and then I'm both probably gonna look at
Instagram because even uh even though uh
some people in our later 20s like myself
still go to Facebook uh the I think most
of the people that are looking for
Fitness are on Instagram everyone
about politics on Facebook I
don't got time for that so go to
Instagram to do that right uh what I
mean what kind of search would I use
because it's like my fear would be I
would cold message a guy and say hey
look you know I was just like I felt
your pain trust me uh you know I was 267
270 some odd pounds two blood pressure
pills I was at I was where you were at
uh these are the life changes I made I'd
love to help you I almost feel like I
might insult a guy going will you
calling me fat or something like that no
I'm calling I'm not calling out in any
of this I'm trying to help you
overcomes a challenge at your face cool
yeah so great great question
um the concept from build to serve is
the fast passive Freedom where you're
creating a little bit of content for
your page and then it's mostly based on
Outreach messaging people to offer to
help and it's the fastest way to be able
to grow your business but it's one that
a lot of people don't like to use
because it risks rejection and people
ignoring you or uh not understanding you
and you know a lot of times people don't
like doing kind of the Outreach and the
sales
um for you I would actually look at two
options I would look at Instagram I
think is smart
um
yeah I think Instagram is going to be
your best bet
okay
um maybe Discord
but really just yeah I would start with
Instagram
uh for your demo and I would look at two
different sets of hashtags okay the
first would be
something where they're like something
like overweight okay like where they're
where they're acknowledging so you're
not calling them fat
right they're already self-acknowledging
like overweight dad
especially if you're targeting
apparently like overweight might be too
big you can see how much content's
coming in but overweight men overweight
dad
and see what they post and and
you'll have some people who are posting
because it's deeply personal to them
because they're struggling they're
frustrated like why am I so overweight
and and I'm I'm fell back off the train
and like they're they're sharing their
life and they're pouring their heart and
looking for some kind of support right
that's somebody that you're very
empathetic to you're saying hey I went
through this too I'd love to hop on a
call and I've got a couple strategies I
think might work right so the whole
point is the Outreach is to get them to
then check your profile and you look
legit with what you've done and hop on a
call to talk to you about strategies
that then could lead to
coaching or whatever else you're trying
to sell right okay um so that's a much
more empathetic approach because they're
pouring their heart out and they're
probably going to get some comments and
support from their friends but nobody
who can actually help them where you
could actually help
um so yeah you can definitely position
it so that it's not
making fun of them because that's not
what's in your heart you'll also have
the people who are kind of making the
light of it
okay right so whether they're using
hashtag overweight or overweight dads or
even that's where like Dad bod could be
one that you look at
where they're not they're not showing
how they are struggling with it they're
kind of leaning into the humor of it
okay saying look at me haha dad bod you
know like uh he was me at 20 now now I'm
but laughing at it and they're they're
using comedy as uh you know they're
struggling yeah they're just using
comedy right right so for that person
when you're reaching out
you can say hey I saw your post on that
bot like you you lean in on the humor a
little bit more when you say but you
know what if you ever need help
and you want to lose a dad bod
I'd be happy to hop on a call and help
you okay okay unless like you're leaning
into the humor of it unless the empathy
because that's the spirit of the post
that they put up okay my second question
if I may is uh I I the guy that I work
with is my coach after I got certified
to become one has him and I have talked
about
um the conversations have gone on for a
while about becoming a coach under his
um umbrella but I know he's really busy
with everything he's got going on on his
own stuff so it might be a while before
him and I get to that point and I was
talking with Zan last week and and
there's even mentions in your book too
kind of like do the both and like you
know you do you and also partner up with
other people my concern is that if I
start my own thing without even him
putting me under him it might ruin a
friendship and a but possible business
relationship is there a way to to just
reach out to me go hey I'm thinking of
branching out at least starting to build
a clientele which will give me the job
experience plus I could work alongside
you but the things I've learned from him
I don't want to like sell off as my own
because well even if there's not a
copyright to it it's just dishonest do
you know what I'm saying yeah
honest conversation yeah okay
that's that's uh
is he in your city can you go see him
face to face or he's across the country
somewhere else lives in North Carolina
and I'm in the sunny Tropical Paradise
of Cleveland Ohio
okay
got it uh simi's happy with the
Cleveland
um yeah that that's a zoom call then
like video
that's not something you handle over
email okay and
what he needs to see is that you're like
he needs to feel your heart and so even
if you kind of stumble on the words and
what you're trying to say okay the fact
that you care about him and what
he has taught you and that you you're
not your intention is not to just steal
his stuff and go do your own thing okay
but you're also looking at like what
kind of relationship this is almost the
same as like you know samit when we
started this conversation up he wants he
wants something more than what he's
getting okay at his at his company and
so in sumit's case it was a no I was
like no we can't do that okay so
ultimately somebody needs to leave and
go find something else you know for him
to be happy like if you see if he's
still in the same spot in five years
that's a problem you know five months
okay you know as long as we're making
progress with five years is a problem
for you maybe there's something new that
could be created like maybe he sees a
bigger spark in you that could lead to a
unique kind of relationship that you're
not just fitting into his typical mold
of what everybody else would be as a
trainer right maybe he wants you to go
and help train his trainers or create
some new division or like you never know
until you bring it up okay
so and I think that has to be done
ideally face to face but again you know
if you're not flying over there but but
Zoom at least so you can see you and and
feel your heart and your even again you
stumble over the words but he
understands better than like just a
well-crafted perfect email that's a
little heartless that could be taken the
wrong way because you inject your own
tone sometimes in a text or an email
that wasn't there from the author yeah I
mean if it's a big deal it may even be
worth flying over there
right I mean how much is a flight to
wherever like it's only eight hour drive
I can drive out there but sure like it's
it's the
um there's two things there it's like
the extra benefit of spending the time
face to face with them but also the
amount of effort that you put in to make
that happen
also speaks about like I really value
this that I would drive eight hours to
come and and see you
right shows how much you actually care
about this and it's not just a throwaway
conversation
coaching
you know
Tanya what do we got hello Tyson today
that's my lucky day
what do you do when you launch something
and it goes terrible
after that what do you mean it goes
terrible
because
um I I normally do lives for my company
and I have normally between like 30 and
50 people and we don't really do like
it's organic just you know people that
and I've been doing this since once like
probably two or three months ago once
um Sans suggested you should go live
every week and I started doing it and it
has been working well more appointments
really nicely so I started thinking okay
let's do something else something
different so we um I you know uh
proposed uh we should do a workshop a
paid Workshop to have people who's only
interested in actually you know
um doing the the registration in the
programs we have and I uh said well we
should do like a very low fee just to
have the commitment and I'm kind of like
to test the market which is something
that we have also took in these meetings
so I did that and um and I was uh you
know I had a conversation with one of
the colleges here in in in Canada with
Seneca College which is fairly big and
they even give us they even gave us some
budget to do the you know the the
promotion and all so we use the budget
and everything so we had people asking
we had people you know lots of likes
lots of cards and all that but it's a
little bit embarrassing but just one
actually payment came through just one
okay and it's today okay and it's coming
up or or it hasn't happened yet it's
today yeah today at 7 p.m oh good I so
so listen this is great like
one is worse than zero right it's better
like if nobody shows up because then you
don't have to do anything right but one
person shows up and then it's like one
person
um
you lean into it
right like you lean first off are are
you
is there anybody who you're afraid of
disappointing right obviously we're
afraid of disappointing the one person
who paid for the thing because we we
need to give them value are we afraid
that like Santa's gonna be upset that we
didn't get more people or is there
anybody is there anybody besides the one
person that you're afraid of
disappointing
yeah like
it was probably yeah my the the rest of
directors in the in the firm were not
that happy
um in the sense that you know I I kind
of like uh
promoted these and uh instead of doing
what we regularly do and uh you know
they were not that happy but at the end
it's not the end of the world the worst
part would be
um those the person who paid but it's
just one so I don't have a problem I'll
have the consultation with him
um you know a free consultation and that
will pay whatever he paid because it was
just ten dollars it was just very very
little fee just to get those who are
really interested so that's not it's
more like
to like what should I like I don't think
it's gonna be a good idea even if we
have a couple more registrations I don't
think it's a good idea to do the
workshop Maybe
I don't know if it's better just to meet
with them one-on-one or maybe should I
go and do the workshop and kind of like
swallow the the the the the the bad
moments like with three people there and
of course I had to explain I have to
explain Seneca College that this didn't
work the market the market I work with
it's very
tough in that sense of pain so and this
was a test yeah so it didn't work it's
kind of like I mean that moment that
what should I do now
you make a list of anybody who you're
afraid of like the judgments and then we
attack the list so if it's your if your
uh directors at your firm are upset you
can you can handle that like you know
how to talk to them it's a test guys we
need to test we can't just keep doing
the same thing and instead of me
spending my time doing personal stuff
I'm spending time on this like this is
this is an attempt right so we can we
can handle them Seneca if you're worried
that you spent their money and it didn't
get a result well what else could we do
to deliver value for them build the
relationship right it's just like
there's lots of things that you could do
that either are outside of this one
this one um advertising
you know mistake air quotes uh that you
can just bring value to that
relationship like if I went and I
totally bombed on uh Brendan wants me to
speak at his event next month right if I
go upstage and like forget what I'm
gonna say and just totally bomb cool I
can make it up to him like if something
happened and I sucked on stage I could
make it up I would find a way to make it
up to bring incredible value to him and
his team so you can make it up to the
people of Seneca
um so the one person you just go and
crush and give them tons of value right
I mean you can even lean into it it's
like hey this was a test for us
you're the you're the person who took
action I love you like let's go and and
you just again you focus on who you have
instead of who you don't if I look at
this like you know how many people do we
have live here why if it was one person
it was you me and Zayn we would still do
this and we'd have a good time helping
we've got I don't know 12 people if it
was a hundred people like we'd still
it doesn't like you can make the
decision whether you keep going or not
but you can you can bring tons of value
to that one person so that helps
alleviate everything because you can you
know you can make it up to everybody you
know you can bring value to everybody
and nobody's going to be pissed at you
after today right cool
the next thing I pay attention to is did
you love the thing like my first
speaking gig in Toronto was that the
YMCA for free and three people showed up
after I promoted it and they promoted it
for free in a giant room I show up with
this giant like Auditorium and there's
three people who are there like oh my
gosh what is this I feel like the
biggest failure of all time
um and I decided Well I already did my
presentation like I already know I
already prepared so much and I was so
nervous because it was one of my first
presentations and um
I just went and did it and it was
amazing
you know it's like I have to I have to
keep going and logically it doesn't make
any sense like if if I promoted it and
nobody showed up and the YMCA promoted
it to their members and nobody like
nobody three people showed up how am I
ever gonna make this this is not a
business this is stupid
but I loved it
and so I kept doing it and I found a way
right so more important than did this
work do workshops work absolutely
so something in the in the in the
mechanics of it didn't work something in
the marketing and promotion of it didn't
work something in the copy didn't work
something on the in the video didn't
work or the advertising was spent
incorrectly like there's many things
that probably didn't work
that doesn't mean that the project is
dead because workshops work
it's more you do it with this one person
and you see do did I love this
and if you love helping them then you
have one now and you try to fix the
marketing for the next time and then you
have three or five or seven or ten or
Twenty or like it just keeps building
but the the test isn't did it work or
not because nothing works the first time
like the the chances of something
working the first time I was talking to
the president of Shopify right and you
guys know Shopify you can build your
website and sell so
he was saying that all of the um if you
combine all the Shopify stores together
and a Canada's one store they'd be the
second largest store in the world after
Amazon crazy
um and what he said was almost everybody
who's had success on Shopify if you look
at the people who like sold a million
dollars plus through Shopify
it was like their third or fourth store
on Shopify like they had tried Shopify
before and it didn't work out didn't
work out right so like but kept going
started another store where the biggest
mistake is starting one store it doesn't
work oh I guess it's not for me and then
you quit and that's the story of almost
every entrepreneurs like they struggled
and they failed and they sucked at the
beginning and they just kept going so
it definitely can work
for sure workshops work advertising work
it works you just didn't execute it
great
cool
expect to suck and not execute great at
the beginning it's fine you go and
deliver for this person did you love it
was it fun could you imagine five ten
100 people there and it being fun yes
then you keep going
um no then you stop you know so but
that's much more of a heart decision
because your your head can figure it out
with enough repetition
thank you the help went a little I went
on a little speech there but I got
excited
it's so exciting because like I can I
can now say you know I felt like the
Biggest Loser of all time when I was at
the YMCA doing that event like I felt
like I wanted to go and hide like I
can't believe I'm such a failure this is
ridiculous plus I pinned my whole career
now like this is what I'm gonna do for
the rest of my life I'm so excited like
oh I can't do this like this is not
gonna work so it's this giant failure
moment
um
but I'm so excited that that happened
because now I can share that story right
people will be inspired in in five years
ten years by your success they can say
guys when I started
I got one person it was 10 bucks and
only one person showed up the crazy I
felt like the biggest loser
and but I kept going and here's what
happened right
um if you're perfect at the beginning
then it's actually not inspiring other
people
so just go and like just give love to
this person go crush it for them
and then see if you liked it and if you
loved it then then keep doing it if not
you move on to something else
yes I'll have an inspiring speech after
tonight there you go I love it and
listen whenever I'm afraid to do
something
um that'll be one of the things because
I'm I'm afraid of disappointing people
so when I'm afraid of doing something I
will ask myself like can I make it up if
I screw this up can I make it up to
people
you know and the answer is like I can
always find a way to make it up to
people so cool let's do it like when my
tour got canceled
my 20
20 tour when did I break my neck it's 20
20. uh 2019 I broke my neck we did it so
2020 I was doing another tour and we had
sold tickets Across America like 22
cities we were promoting spending money
advertising pitching
selling tickets to and I'm I'm about to
go across the border and speak in
wherever like Buffalo or whatever my
first speaking gig and I get denied at
the border and it shuts down the whole
the whole trip
and so now we have to
it's like all these people who bought
tickets to come see me and now I can't
do any of them because I got stopped at
the border and so like panic mode right
away like oh my gosh this is the most
terrible thing of all time I feel bad
for the two people who my camera guy and
my driver who was Jeremy at the time
were coming along and they got stopped
they playing for this
um but like okay I can make it up to
Jeremy my first I can make it up to
Jeremy and Ray who are coming with me
I'm gonna take him to the to The Keg
which is a kind of fancy Steakhouse here
in Canada and just tell them get
whatever you want just it's on me by the
fanciest steak whatever you want it's on
me because I feel guilty for like you
committed three months of your life to
come with me and now it's all over
and they were fine and I told them I
felt guilty like no no this is great no
worries
and then it's all the people who bought
tickets to my event like I can make it
up to them can I make it up to them yes
like a personal message to everybody
obviously refund but like a refund for
me Isn't Enough so it's a personal
message to everybody I think we even
offered like a call
like a call with me if if they have
bought the ticket within a certain
amount of time or something
um so like you can always make it up to
people and people know your heart and
your care and your like the intention
behind this
they're they're pretty forgiving like if
you make a mistake and you own up to it
and you try to make it better it often
leads to just amazing relationships as
well honestly one of my biggest regrets
in thinking about this like get save the
name email phone number contact
information of this one person
so that in five years or ten years we
can like do an IG live with them or
something he's like you were the one
person only one verse like I don't know
who the three people were who that would
be the best thing of all time like who
are the three people who came to my
first thing being able to have them on
now
and say you were there at the YMCA right
I wish I had kind of kept in touch
um so yeah if you had their contact info
that could be a cool now we're turning
into something much bigger but um
yeah I didn't even have his credit card
information well there you go
build the relationship honestly like
follow them on social if they have it
like build like if you love doing it and
it becomes something man that first
person to be able to say only one person
showed up and we're still in touch and
here's what they're doing and and show
the success that you're able to help
them with
yeah I wish I I wish I was smart enough
to think about that when I was first
getting started with those three people
I want to know I don't remember them I
was so nervous and so scared and so
feeling like a loser I can't even see
their faces the three people who showed
up so
um yeah that'd be pretty cool thank you
yeah yeah I think and what you helped me
help me bring value to each of the parts
involved because I'm not afraid of you
know falling down and hit the floor
right you know it had happened before
and I know that I can you know uh stand
up again I know that so yeah it was kind
of like very disappointing to to to
listen that there was just one
registration yeah but I can't I can
survive that but yes I was concerned
about all the all the other parties you
know that are involved in this but I
think that I can made up for them and
yeah I'll definitely I'll definitely
find a way to and you gave me with the
process of thinking that so thank you
thank you so much there we go well
that's why Community is so important
this week's topic was Maria who picked
Niche picking one and staying with it
had a narrow when in it to include
another Niche uh well since we have
Maria here why don't we uh Workshop this
a little bit what what's uh what's on
your mind where's this coming from
thank you Evan and thank you so much for
I'm just blown away with your generosity
with the challenge and
anyway uh thank you so I've been you
know I've I've shifted my Niche a few
times over the years because I I address
women that struggle in their
relationship to food Weight and Body
Image but it's typically the tip of the
iceberg and usually the deeper blocks
the emotional blocks sometimes trauma
sometimes Stress Management sometimes
that's where you have to go to have
long-term healing and so
I'm you know I I Market to that
particular population but I work with
people that struggle with anxiety and
because that's usually the next layer
right people are medicating with food
it's a lot of times they're medicating
their anxiety or their and one of the
things I just watched your interview
with Melanie because I I am a emotional
Freedom techniques Master practitioner
and that's one of the techniques that I
actually use to one of them that help
people to have more peace in their with
their emotional body so my question is
do I just stick to this Niche or do I
broaden it like when is like when is the
time to do that or do I just keep doing
what I'm doing and because for instance
I'll work with someone and then she'll
send me her husband because her husband
has anxiety issues you know so
I don't know if that's clear no no I
mean they get great and think everybody
kind of struggles with forms of this at
some point when they're figuring out
their content Their audience
um what you need to think about is who
so in in looking at your titles for the
movement makers challenge that we're
going through right now all your titles
came back to helping women right like
everything said women which is fine so
you know I love I'll believe in anybody
I like if somebody if you sent me
somebody who or I'm talking to somebody
who's an employee and never wants to be
an entrepreneur I'll still have the
conversation help them it's just not
really what I want to be doing you know
it's like it's not at the core of what I
love the most because that's I love
serving entrepreneurs more so it doesn't
mean that hey because you're a man I'm
not going to talk to you you know but if
you love serving women then you focus on
that audience first
inside of that
you get the pick is it really mental
health stuff that you love about a love
caring about is it really the weight
loss Journey because that leads to the
mental health stuff you know like who do
you love helping the most like if you
had to pick we all love serving we all
love helping if we see somebody fall on
the street we're gonna go and and help
them up I hope readers built to serve
readers okay you see somebody follow the
street you go help them up
but that's not like what we want to you
know be spending our days doing it's
just we see somebody in need and we do
what we can to support
um
you know right now uh the whole thing in
Ukraine like my main video editor her
she's Ukrainian and she left three uh no
she left like five years ago from
Ukraine to go to Montenegro and
um
because of war and potential war and all
that so she's safe but her family is in
the Ukraine and we've been spending the
past time kind of figuring out hey how
how can I help I mean I I'm in Canada
like do they need money like is your
family safe can they fly out of the
country can they get somewhere where
they need to go you know I I don't speak
the language or have any connections but
uh if if money is a problem to get
people what they need like let me know
um and you know I'm helping with that
but it's not what I want I my mission
isn't going into war-torn countries and
helping people escape but you know right
so we do what we can to serve the people
who are around us but like who do you
who would you spend or love spending the
most time with it's like just absolutely
feeds your soul who are they and what
are they struggling with in the
challenge of the movement makers
the thing we're going through right now
is to try to get it more specific so
that when you're making the content it's
not just how to fix your anxiety
which is great but specific to like who
are the people who love helping them out
so in that context who do you who would
you love helping like the most the most
the most yeah so
my word is care and my mission really is
I feel passionate about this is to to
help women to get beyond the struggles
that undermine them so that they can
stand in their life and and be their
best self and and serve in the way that
they've been called to serve because I
feel like the advancement of women and
you know we in this country we have we
have more freedom than many women on the
planet and yet we're emotionally
oppressed by Body Image issues and
weight issues and and all that chips
away at us being our best self so I feel
passionate about that and also my story
is about that I've come from multiple
eating disorders and I've worked in so I
you know I'm on the other side of that
now and I feel like my purpose is my
passion I mean my pain has been my
passion
so yes that's that gives me greatest
pleasure when I have clients that are
you know getting beyond the dieting
stuff and and really looking you know
living a Freer life and they're and
they're finding their purpose beyond
that and not teaching their little
daughters to be over concerned about
diet and weight but that these girls can
come into the world with more empowered
about
who they are as a person not necessarily
how they look so I mean that's part of
it yeah I mean I love I love that you so
you have your Niche women which is
awesome now now that's like
half of the population so we've narrowed
it down a little bit but
getting a little more specific to then
the next step and the problem that
they're facing is helpful because if you
only said women who who aren't living
their best lives that's everybody that's
every woman that's every man too by the
way you know
separating their potential whatever so
it's very it's very broad which which is
the long-term Mission but then inside of
that who do you love helping the most
and whether it relates to food or not
that's the discussion to start to figure
out it's like hey we can we can start to
build this Niche and then expand from
there but inside of that like who do you
love love love helping the most like do
you love helping
teenage girls get over a crush that
broke their heart on Prom Night do you
love helping
you know a woman who might have lost her
mom yesterday to cancer you know like
there's so many issues that we will face
and so it's great to Target women but
then what are they struggling with the
most that you love helping them through
and then that becomes
most of the content that you start with
so you can start building your tribe
around it yeah yeah yeah yeah
well it is women that are caught in in
struggling
with weight thinking they need a diet
that's going to fix them because it's
really an inside job right and so I get
great set like for instance I've been
working with a new client recently and
after a couple of weeks she's come to
the realization that it's really not
about her weight her unhappiness and her
and that gives me great gratification
and satisfaction yes she wants to still
be healthy and treat her body with
respect but giving up the struggle and
learning to trust herself more is
that that's what gives me great
gratification that she's she's really
feeling more of
um taking caring enough about herself
that she is willing to have healthier
boundaries with her husband and rather
than focusing on the body image and all
of that getting beyond that is that is
that clear yeah yeah I think that's
great like behind every for all
everybody here you want to have an
impact and we all have a message to to
serve other people
these strategies alone are not going to
be enough
like just telling somebody here's what
you do here's the foods to eat if I
could just tell somebody hey make these
videos go that's not enough because
there's there's emotional resistances to
everything
so you could tell somebody to eat this
food but there's a reason why they're
abusing the food in the first place all
of us have blocks that prevent us from
doing the next thing and so
understanding that really helps so
woman you're helping they're they're
stressed out or they have anxiety they
have body issues and some of them the
ones who you'll like helping the most
they solve they they feed their anxiety
and stress with food
others might do it through drugs others
might do nothing or relationships or
they cut themselves or they you know
like and so that's where like well do
you want to help those women too if
somebody's saying like I've tried to
kill myself four times because I hate my
body and like maybe maybe you don't turn
that person away you know but it's not
like the core of what you want to deal
with because it's not the same path that
you went through right so if women great
awesome plus anxiety stress
self-confidence issues great that's
going to be everybody but how do they
fix though how are they getting their
fix off is through food
yeah and so you're still addressing the
underlying thing but also helping them
solve the connection to getting their
fix with food right so it's like food
but you're not just gonna teach diet
plans no you're going to teach them
techniques underneath it's not that
those techniques no really of course and
but it's not just that those techniques
only work through food
they could also apply to people who are
cutting themselves or oh yes or for men
too who are doing these it's just not as
much
of a connection to you because you
haven't gone through those things yeah
well I've gone through other addictive
behaviors and and and on because really
my understanding you know if you if you
just transfer one addiction to another
the expression is you're changing seats
on the Titanic I mean you're not
addressing the underlying you're still
going down right and what years ago when
I worked in an eating disorder unit by
the time people got there they had gone
through drug addiction and and gambling
addiction and so all of that stuff is
relevant and yes though as I work with
people for instance I'll work with
somebody who's a food issue and then all
of a sudden after a couple weeks they
feel safe enough with me to real to to
reveal that they drink a bottle of wine
every night and so as we uncover
the core reasons so it's you know on the
onset I I'm I tracked people and
sometimes people don't over well I guess
it has more to do with Rapport and
intimacy and Trust as they get to know
me and they feel safe with me then they
reveal more
about who they are and also knowing if
you've been through the thing that
they're going through because you can
make the connection between addictive
behaviors but other people may not right
so like have you ever lost your home
because of a gambling problem
well my father was a compulsive gambling
Gambler and we lost many homes
but so that's that speaks to like family
so my family member is doing this but
have you ever done it
have I lost a home I haven't lost a home
but I've
lost a lot I don't have a gambling issue
great so but I have an issue with
supporting men because that came out of
that Dynamic that my mother I've had in
my history I don't do that today but in
my history I've supported men and given
them a lot of money
great I'm a little ashamed of even
saying that but it was because of the
Dynamics of the gambling
you know so that was well listen you're
in a safe space and thank you for having
the courage to share that with us if you
haven't told other people before but
these are things that you can speak to
right it's not that if somebody has
their own gambling problem
um you won't help them but it's just not
it's not you you you didn't go and lose
your home but if somebody came and said
my father has again or my mother or
somebody my family has a gambling
addiction or I keep supporting people
for some reason why do I keep supporting
these men who have gambling problems
what is wrong with me like somebody that
person you would love helping so much
more than I have a gambling problem
because it's more through your
experience of what you've lived like if
somebody came to you and said I keep
supporting men who have gambling
problems what's wrong with me and then
you help them realize there's nothing
wrong with you
right and you teach them to actually
love yourself and just get out of these
negative relationships that's going to
make you feel amazing yes so it's and
hopefully I mean we're spending a lot of
time on this but hopefully everybody can
see that kind of similar Journey for
your own self the thing that you have
been through where you felt hopeless
worthless like when your dad did that
and you lost your home or you gave money
and
just how terrible like it made you feel
terrible about yourself and if you then
subsidize through food like okay well
I'm just gonna go eat that pizza or
Doritos or whatever just to make me feel
good because I don't have any happiness
in my life anywhere right like this is
where people get really stuck so that's
your Niche you know the people who are
currently struggling with the thing that
you struggled through and it doesn't
mean we ignore everybody else we can't
help them and we're going to turn them
away but it's not who we're actively
trying to go out and serve because if
you just go out and say ladies have more
self-confidence it becomes too broad a
message
but then you end up we end up trying to
serve everybody and ends up serving very
few people
does that help yes it's very helpful
the modalities that I do use is tapping
and I really love the conversation you
had with Melanie because it's not all
the only thing I use and but a lot of my
YouTube videos have been focused on that
because there's a whole niche of people
that are but I use the tapping specific
to that weight body image and so so like
who I how right that from Bill to serve
that's the how the how the how matters
less about what the how is and matters
more that you believe in the how like if
if somebody sees you and say I'm in the
same situations Maria I've been over
eating to combat my stress because of
whatever happened in my life and you're
gonna say I'm exactly like you here's
how I got through it tapping great show
me how to do it like the how does it
matter
what matters is that it actually worked
for you yeah and that because I love you
and I connect to your story I'm gonna
now have more belief in the strategy
that you're gonna give me on how to get
out as well so if tapping helped you
then incorporate it into your content
yes if it helped you for everything
great put it everywhere if it helped you
only for specific problems just make it
for those specific problems but bringing
it into your content bring it into your
coaching whatever got you out of the
hole
is the thing then you teach other people
because that's your job is to get them
out of the hole that they're in as well
and we all have we all have different
house right and you don't have to use
the same have for every situation but
how did you get out of the situation you
were in and now we teach that yeah we're
thought leaders
I love it it just reminds me of somebody
booked a consult with me tomorrow and
when I when somebody books I ask them to
just put anything that they have to say
and she said she said I'm not sure about
tapping but I'm sure about you she's
been following me for a while yeah and
um it really just spoke to what you were
saying she felt comfortable enough to
have the consult with me to potentially
work with me
but she wasn't sure about tapping yeah
like the how doesn't matter this is why
in movement makers for this challenge
that we're doing when when I'm rejecting
everybody putting in their like their
four steps to do things or the three
ways or the age like the strategies do
not matter
what matters is the connection to you I
don't giving me eight strategies is not
the benefit
what's the specific the specific benefit
that I'm gonna get from working with you
and so that's the whole game if you get
them to to know you like you trust you
which comes from you telling your story
if I start talking about women's weight
issues
you're not a woman you don't know me you
don't know what I'm going through right
like it's going to be the first like who
even if I have all the same strategies
they're not gonna listen to me because
I'm not a woman
right and and that's an obvious like
hopefully you can tell that I'm not a
woman
like that's a pretty obvious thing but
the thing is a lot of these things that
we
have struggled with are not obvious like
knowing that you struggled if I look at
you I don't think you struggle with food
if I look at you I don't think you had
men in your life who had gambling issues
that you supported so when you come out
and say Here's how you solve it it
doesn't come across like who is this
woman who's preaching to me
right you're not and this is hopefully
applicable to everybody like you're not
coming down from your high horse and
preaching people and telling people what
to do you're saying I'm just like you I
was I was in the same spot and I
struggled with this and here's how I
overcame but until you share that story
and I know that you've been through it
and you're at you're like me then then
I'm not going to listen to you so anyway
most things are not obvious right men
women obvious you know ethnic background
whatever scar on your face like super
obvious but most of the things we deal
with is not obvious and so we need to
share those things and have the courage
and you honestly did it right here it's
like I'm a little embarrassed to say
this it's great
and sharing that will only connect more
people to you like nobody if any people
only feel more love for you in saying
that you struggled with supporting men
who had gambling addictions not oh I'm
not going to talk to Maria now because
of that so thank you for having the
courage to uh to share up thank you Evan
thank you for all that you do thank you
if you want to get a copy of Bill to
serve and join us live for our next
training with me to ask your questions
you can go get the book right there next
to me right there I'll see you there
I'll see you to get the book it's a good
one much love